bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 société
au lendement de la 26e journée mondiale
de lutte contre le sida nous avons voulu
dresser un état des lieux de la
situation rappelé sur tous les
dispositifs de prévention mises en place
dans le département et plus
particulièrement à saint quentin en
yvelines en plateau avec nous le dr alix
border blanc bonsoir vous êtes
responsable du centre dépistage gratuit
et anonyme
le cdag qui est basé notamment ali ps de
trappes et vous êtes aussi médecin
l'unité des maladies infectieuses et
tropicales au sein de l'hôpital mignot
du chesnay sûrement très bon soir même
soirée téléfilm merci nous avoir sa
roubles engagement de téléphiles la
lutte l'esprit saint pour faire dire ça
m'a demandé mais c'est une cause
important qui nous tient à coeur est
président d'hachette prévention une
association qui intervient en
ile-de-france pas que de france et
notamment dans les yvelines au plus près
des populations c'est peut-être ça la
marque de fabrique c'est les populations
visible et vous avez également une
antenne ps ali ps de trappes et puis là
les vilains bonsoir merci beaucoup de
votre participation vous êtes trésorier
de l'association et vous êtes également
malade séropositif depuis plusieurs
années alors zéro nouvelle infection du
vih zéro discrimination et zéro décès dû
au sida c'est le thème retenu en 2014
pour cette journée mondiale du sida et
l'objectif et c'est toujours d'éradiquer
l'épidémie dans le monde d'ici 2030
ça paraît un objectif atteignable sa
part et surtout illusoire mais
effectivement donc les gens aiment bien
se projeter en disant que la lutte
contre le sida il y aura une fin
l'espère tout ce qui est une fin
malheureusement dans palpe line
médicamenteuse c'est à dire la recherche
pour l'instant il n'ya rien avant au
moins 20 à 30 ans et la recherche
vaccinale patine avance mais patine
quand même donc c'est pas pour demain et
nous le conseil s'est effectivement de
continuer à faire ce que dit
effectivement les autorités c'est à dire
le pilier de la prévention et le pilier
du dépistage la prévention ça passe par
le préservatif le dépistage
effectivement c'est important de
connaître son statut et c'est vrai que
pour le coup ça permettrait vrai
d'endiguer à terme peut-être le virus du
sida donc 2030 c'est pas pour bientôt on
va parler du vaccin est évidemment
dépistage et de la prévention on le sait
toujours à l'occasion de la journée
mondiale du talent on attend ça nous
donnait beaucoup de chiffres et les
sites sont assez alarmants massif c'est
important mais là du coup on nous
abreuve de beaucoup de chiffres
l'impression une fois par an seulement
ils sont assez alarmiste notamment ces
deux chiffres il ya une enquête de la
smerep de mai 2014 qui dit que 2,2
étudiant sur trois n'utilisent pas
systématiquement le préservatif 31 %
affirme même ne jamais se protéger et
l'an dernier un peu plus de onze mille
huit cents personnes ont été dépistés
positifs au virus vih du sida c'est un
chiffre publié par liane vs en
augmentation de 7% par rapport à 2011 il
faut forcément s'en inquiéter et
pourquoi ce relâchement de guillemets
c'est une explosion du chiffre tout
simplement parce que jusqu'à présent on
nous disait vous savez il ya toujours
six à sept mille cas de contamination là
faut rappeler effectivement 11800
personnes ont été découvertes
séropositives entre 1013 on était venus
l'année dernière vous dire qu'il y avait
un vrai problème que nous on ressentait
sur le terrain qu'ils avaient de plus en
plus de personnes séropositives et qui
avait de plus en plus de personnes qui
découvrent leur séropositivité
on avait fait aussi car dans les
universités qui avait un vrai problème
est un vrai relâchement de la prévention
que les jeunes n'utilisaient plus le
préservatif c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'on a sorti l'application tubes pour
trouver donc des préservatifs mais
effectivement ça se traduit aujourd'hui
dans les chiffres des chiffres qui sont
effectivement nationaux 7% de plus de
personnes séropositives c'est juste
scandaleux aujourd'hui effectivement il
faudrait beaucoup plus de prévention
beaucoup plus de prise en compte de
conscience de la part des gens parce
qu'on ne pourra pas continuer avec une
épidémie qui repart on avait réussi
effectivement la stabiliser donc
continuer à dire que ce n'était pas
suffisant et là effectivement si ça
repart sa voix posée est effectivement
un vrai problème quel regard docteur
avec sa grand mère vous portait
justement sur ces chiffres on voit qu'il
ya une nette augmentation et nette
recrudescence des nouvelles
contaminations
il ya sans doute eu une prévention un
peu différente qui est plus ciblée
beaucoup de gens se sentent moins
concernés ou peu concernés notamment les
jeunes certaines personnes réagissent en
dix ans maintenant on a un traitement on
a une trithérapie efficace donc au pire
si je suis contaminé je prendrai le
prévenu alors que c'est quand même des
traitements qui sont lourds qui ont des
effets secondaires qui aujourd'hui en
tout cas son quotidien
et donc ça reste quelque chose de quand
même très très très lo alors c'est vrai
que les traitements ont fait énormément
de progrès c'est vrai que grâce aux
trithérapies ça a changé la vie des gens
c'est vrai qu'on a vu après 1996 les
gens à arrêter de mourir et maintenant
on a un pronostic bien meilleure pour
les personnes qui sont séropositives
mais ça reste une maladie chronique
avec lettres et les ventes ne guérit pas
ah c'est une maladie aujourd'hui dont on
ne guérit pas le traitement même les
meilleurs traitements qu'on a
actuellement efficace trithérapie etc
c'est un traitement qu'on doit prendre à
vie dès qu'on arrête le traitement même
si on a pris le traitement pendant dix
ans très bien dès qu'on arrête le
traitement on sait très bien que la
charge virale c'est à dire la quantité
de virus présente dans le sang va
remonter au bout de dix quinze jours en
fonction des gens ou trois semaines
enfin dans un délai assez court et
xavier villain alors je dis vous êtes
séropositif depuis plusieurs années
depuis qu'elles vont vous avez détecté
votre de en 2002 alors quand le docteur
alix oeuvre des revenantes parle
effectivement d'un de traitement qui
sont assez lourds vous confirmez c'est
ce que nous disent en général tous les
tous les malades oui c'est bien que dans
en
2002 c'était avant l'apparition des
trithérapies qui étaient là en quantité
de prix des médicaments
avec l'évolution depuis 12 ans on est
arrivé à avoir des traitements avec une
prise en mono prise par jour un cachet
par jour à prendre ça facilite deux
modes de
prise de ces médicaments mais alors ça
facilite le mode de près à ce médicament
mais est-ce que ça évite les effets les
effets secondaires et ça ne recréent
quelques uns des faits secondaires d
agréer des effets secondaires qui sont
plus visibles et donc je n en a des
effets secondaires plus invisible qui
sont tous à dire lors d'un des organes
qui vont plus souffrir par rapport pas
dans nos coeurs des reins le foie mon ya
tous les choses qui vont se mettre en
place pour une cavalière qui sait qu'à
plus vite par rapport au ca ces
traitements non mais on accélère on n'a
pas le choix de les prendre pour
continuer à vivre si vous avez à vivre
un de ses traitements donc il faut tous
les jours prenez un voilà tous les soirs
je prends mon comprimé en mangeant et je
suis tranquille que demain ça
oui oui oui oui parce qu'il faut pas le
voilà bon
il faut y voi il faut essayer de ne pas
l'oublier ça peut arriver c'est pas
rêver de maps réponse vrai que tant
qu'on n'est pas dans les sept jours
double il n'y a pas d'inquiétude mais il
faudra en observant c'est très important
pour garder ses charge virale
indétectable puis être se protéger
soi-même et protéger les autres aussi
autour de soi pas la maladie c'est après
et des hauts et des bas comme tout le
monde mais la fatigue et toux voilà donc
ce qui est plus difficile à cette main
d'ici la fatigue qu'on ressent pas ce
qu'on est dès qu'on a beaucoup
d'activités en n'ai moi même par rapport
à la ma ville je elle même puis les
traitements qui sont assez lourds donc
on a besoin de
metropolit a si peu plus souvent que de
personnes qui vont être séronégatif qui
vont être plus même un travail et à
l'emploi il est pâtissier avant il
restait 12 13 heures par jour debout que
le même temps où trois heures faut que
je m'assoie les arrêtés de travailler
géante est arrivé au pays
est ce que le regard des autres a changé
sur vous on parle souvent de la
discrimination qui est porté sur les
malades séropositifs est ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous avez vous
ressenti moi personnellement non sérieux
gilles parent pas tension
personnellement je n'ai pas ouvert là
dessus puis vous regardez les autres
bien différent parce que vont autrement
ça me protège en même temps si je
commence à faire attention et de les
hôpitaux aux autres je serai plus à
force de vivre donc pratiquement je
préfère mon avance et protégez moi voilà
après le reste oui les gens qui se
sentent discriminés bien sûr on combat
la sérophobie c'est ce qu'il faut mais
bon peut pas officiellement empêcher les
la bêtise humaine déjà on sait comme
pour d'autres maladies c'était pour le
cancer ya quelques années on considère
un concert comme la peste si ça c'est
pas une pourquoi peu de temps s'est
passé j'ai choisi
quel regard vous vous portez sur
justement c'est alors ce sont des
chiffres mais quand même quand vous
entendez que 31 % des étudiants
affirment ne jamais se protéger que deux
étudiants sur trois n'utilisent pas
systématiquement préserver team quoi
c'est waou oui je dis tu peut basculer
de l'autre côté en quelques wild ronde
parce que oui c'est dire que si c'est un
peu aussi un retour qu'on a par rapport
à depuis quelques années on a bondi de
4,1 cézac et très thérapie on nous dit
c'est ma des chroniques ont ni les
traitements ces exemples plus allégée
oui donc les gens ce qu'ils ont ben ils
vont prendre plus de risques parce que
automatiquement aux herbes on sait rien
fait comme un diabète c'est comme autre
chose j'ai panda médicaments puis ça me
faisait mal à la tête je préférais lyon
bat g le vih je prends une pilule par
jour ils se rendent pas compte derrière
à long terme ce qui est ce que ça fait
et donc c'est le rush mans et puis aussi
le problème du préservatif et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut faut retrouver
les bons moyens comme achats faits au
niveau de la prévention avec 1024 pote
avec le tube avec tous de vraiment de
demorand de préservatifs lui dit qu'on
peut dire pour que les gens se
réapproprient parce que c'est les jeunes
bénévoles
contre
c'est à dire que les les jeunes mais ils
ont pas vécu les années sida donc
effectivement c'est des années qui ont
tué énormément de gens alors aujourd'hui
on meurt plus du sida effectivement le
ministère les agences régionales de
santé les médecins disent voilà c'est
une maladie chronique faut quand même
pas oublier que les trithérapies sont
des bombes nucléaires qu'on lâche dans
l'organisme et qui peuvent effectivement
au fil du temps ravagé l'organisme que
c'est pas une bonne idée aujourd'hui en
france d'être séropositif ou de devenir
séropositif parce qu'effectivement il ya
beaucoup de discrimination alors xavier
a pas forcément subit lui ce type de
discrimination nous on a pas mal
d'adhérents qui effectivement non ce
type de difficultés et c'est vrai que hf
prévention à une approche un peu
différente par rapport aux autres
structures associatives nous on va être
beaucoup plus dans le jeu ludique le
fait d'amener monsieur et madame capote
dans des universités c'est pour ça aussi
qu'on fait les universités rendez vous
compte saint quentin en yvelines presque
six ans et quelques dépistage 13
personnes séropositives 12 étudiants
douze étudiants de moins de 25 ans on
avait alerté à plusieurs reprises des
pouvoirs publics ont 10 ce n'est pas
normal qu effectivement on dépiste des
jeunes de moins de 25 ans qui sont
séropositifs
on se rend bien compte aujourd'hui
qu'avec les chiffres de l'institut
national de veille sanitaire on est bien
sûr les moins de 30 ans qui sont
effectivement de plus en plus contaminés
et on est bien sur les plus de 45 ans
effectivement ce qu'on avait dit les
périodes un peu charnière les deux les
divorces le fait de changer ses
habitudes le fait d'être dans du multi
partenariat sexuelle c'est effectivement
ce qui nous mobilise à h/f prévention
pour continuer à faire du ludique à
sortir des applications ludiques comme
tube où effectivement va à la rencontre
des gens on va parler voir les gens et
c'est vrai que c'est quand même
inquiétant d'avoir un relâchement de la
population générale parce que vous dites
il faut revoir peut-être les méthodes de
prévention et pourtant la france en
matière parmi les pays de l'union
européenne qui ont communiqué leurs
activités de dépistage du sida en 2012
la france est quand même arrivé en tête
suivi par la belgique donc ça veut dire
on dépiste beaucoup en france mais
pourtant il ya des cdag qui existent qui
sont nombreux tout à fait en des pistes
beaucoup en france on dépiste beaucoup
dans les cdag mais sans doute que la
population on dépiste beaucoup et elles
ont fait beaucoup de tests de dépistage
mais finalement on trouve pas beaucoup
dans les centres de dépistage anonyme et
gratuit de personnes séropositives
alors je pense que les gens qui viennent
sont des gens qui sont déjà un peu
informés qu'ils ont déjà des notions de
prévention qui sont se sentent
responsables et donc qui viennent
notamment va par exemple des jeunes qui
sont en couple qui décide d'arrêter le
préservatif ils viennent tous les deux
faire le test donc c'est une très bonne
initiative qu'il faut encourager
effectivement ils sont souvent enfin
heureusement même presque tout le temps
négatifs donc après c'est la question
d'aller chercher les gens qui sont
contaminés là où ils sont cependant il
faut rappeler que dans un cdag ces
anonymes et gratuits et anonymes et
gratuits il faut quand même se déplacer
donc les endroits où se font les
dépistages un certain nombre d'hôpitaux
parfois dans des endroits autre que les
hôpitaux comme ici à trappes à
l'institut de promotion de la santé dont
cali ps après je pense qu'il ya aussi
toute une partie de dépistage qui est
faite par les associations et qui est
plus le travail à mon sens des
associations qui font de la prévention
d'aller dans des lieux de rencontres
spécialisés et où dans des endroits où
on sait qu'il ya une prévalence élevée
de césium censure a effectivement ce
qu'ont dit les cdag on a un maillage
territorial qui est formidable mon à des
centres de dépistage anonyme et gratuit
et ça c'est une richesse que la france a
effectivement on a des bons
professionnels de santé partout sur le
territoire qui reçoivent un public et il
ya une vraie utilité au centre de
dépistage anonyme et gratuit moi c'est
ce que je dis souvent ils sont un peu le
far dans l'obscurité l'endroit où les
gens savent qu'ils peuvent se faire
dépister anonyme enfin de manière
anonyme et de manière gratuite ça c'est
vraiment réseau qu'il faut pas perdre
parce que du coup même pour nous qui
sommes effectivement donc associatif et
qui faisons du dépistage on renvoie
énormément sur les centres de dépistage
anonyme et gratuit parce que c'est leur
métier que de pouvoir effectivement des
pistes et toutes les autres maladies
sexuellement transmissibles nous
aujourd'hui on ne fait que le vih demain
il y aura l'hépatite c il y aura la
syphilis mais en attendant effectivement
ne sera jamais en capacité de faire
toutes les ist il ya un vrai travail de
partenariat qui est fait en réalité avec
les centres de dépistage anonyme et
gratuit et ça c'est un très important et
pour les 50 ans de son élection
parce qu'effectivement on trouve pas
beaucoup dans les centres de dépistage
anonyme et gratuit de personnes
séropositives pour le vih en revanche on
trouve un certain nombre de nos syphilis
non négligeable il ya une recrudescence
de la syphilis mieux actuellement et on
trouve beaucoup alors là de chlamydia
qui sont des infections qui sont
sexuellement transmissibles beaucoup
moins connu du grand public qui sont
faciles à traiter qui peuvent avoir des
conséquences notamment en terme de
fertilité chez la femme c'est l'abonné
posé ses tréteaux et quand c'est pris en
charge quand c'est dépister et donc
c'est l'intérêt de ces centres de
dépistage anonyme et gratuit surtout
quand on peut être six listes en même
temps c'est à dire de dépister les
autres infections sexuellement par
démasquer le cas voilà exactement
permet de d'élargir beaucoup plus et
d'avoir un discours de prévention de
l'ensemble des infections sexuellement
transmissibles et pas seulement sur le
vih par une petite pause dans cette
émission on va aller à la rencontre des
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
on leur a posé la question pensez vous
que l'on fasse assez en matière de
prévention
non je trouve pas justement que l'on
fasse à cette prévention pour le sida
qu'on parle pas assez de la protection
pas seulement auprès des jeunes des gens
d'un certain âge qui se protègent plus
je pense qu'il y assez de prévention
mais peut-être que les gens mais ils
n'en tiennent pas trop content ça aux
jeunes de se prendre en main mais
comprendre qu'un camarade avec cette
maladie québec pour être constant c'est
tout mais faudrait plus d'interventions
dans les collèges dans les lycées
pourquoi pas même sur les sur les
tranches d'âge est un peu plus petit et
après essayer de faire plus de
reportages plus de plus de plus de
médias sur le sur le sujet je trouve que
comparé à l'époque où moi
j'étais ado en fait je trouve qu'on en
parle beaucoup moins c'est toujours des
effets de mode donc à l'époque on en
parlait beaucoup maintenant un parent -
est-ce que ça touche moins de gens je
pense pas elle est de retour sur pato
17,8 société pour parler du vih et du
sida lors on a parlé des jeunes faut
effectivement pas oublier les seniors en
parle dans ce conte trottoirs 18 % des
séropositifs testé en 2012 avait plus de
50 ans cinquante ans par dont 12 pour
cent avaient moins de 25 ans et 70 %
avaient entre 25 et 49 ans jouera
maintenant on repart de trois
thématiques
d'abord le type
faudra parler les jeunes savent pas ce
qu'est le tube l'étude c'est une
application sur mobile pour connaître
les lieux où trouver des préservatifs on
se dit c'est simple de trouver les
préservatifs aux besoins de d'avoir une
application pour ça fait des années que
les gens attendent et eu c'est vrai que
pour le coup ça fonctionne bien à leur
tube c'est effectivement pour trouver un
préservatif mais c'est aussi pour
trouver un lieu de dépistage et on
entend par lieux de dépistage les
centres de dépistage anonyme et gratuit
les phares dans l'obscurité
comme alix qui est effectivement donc à
la trappe ou donc à versailles mais
aussi donc ça permette de trouver les
unités mobiles puisqu'on a référencé
donc les fameux tests rapides
d'orientation dépistage que la chef
prévention fait mais on retrouve aussi
toutes les structures qui font du du
trône le fameux trod un test rapide et
ça on le retrouve donc sur une map on se
géolocalise on peut trouver et les
préservatifs et les lieux de dépistage
nous on souhaitait vraiment faire une
application et des straps 5 rien ça n'a
rien à voir avec les autotests non ça va
mal en quelques instants je voudrais
vraiment avoir votre point de vue sur la
question je pense que ça fait beaucoup
débat et est rapide c'est vraiment des
tests encadrer ces états sont cadrés en
notamment effectivement par des
professionnels résultats dans le bar des
associatifs mais il ya une association
derrière nous a lancé les opérations une
minute pour savoir donc dans les
universités les centres commerciaux les
choeurs de cité et effectivement les
gens peuvent venir se faire tester alors
grâce à l'application tube j'en profite
pour dire que marina carrère d'encausse
et effectivement marraine de tube tu
pètes une application qui a été en pré
lancement depuis joint alors
pré-lancement parce que ça devient à
cartonne il n'ya pas d'autre mot à dire
et effectivement le lancement a eu lieu
la semaine dernière un petit mot sur le
prix du préservatif est ce que le
préservatif est trop cher aujourd'hui en
france le préserver ce ne sera que la
ville jouit pas ce que je ferais bien
faire des campagnes c'est vrai mais bon
voilà on doit les données de natixis a
coûté moins cher que l'on retrouve au
cdag reçu l'annoncé de la fusion c'est
bien sûr c est distribué dans les
consultations médicales aussi on peut en
donner après il ya des dents des
associations aussi on peut en donner
donc globalement ça reste quand même
trop cher
c'est un frein à l'utilisation comme il
faut il faut juste être conscient qu'une
personne séropositifs en terme de cash
et en termes de médicaments et de coûts
c'est environ 2000 euros par mois il
vaudrait mieux donner les préservatifs à
chaque fonction d'un tribut grâce au
ministère de la santé plus de 180000
effectivement le congo et demi la santé
vous entendez claire giraut fait il ya
pas photos lettres c'est ça et nous on
continue effectivement à dire que c'est
important de les distribuer gratuitement
et justement donc l'application au tube
permet de trouver les prêts that if
gratuit mais aussi les préparatifs
payant est juste aussi dire qu'elle a
déjà été téléchargée en phase de
pré-lancement à 30000 exemplaires
un petit mot avant par les autotests
donc des trod on en a parlé sur des
tests rapides ça fonctionne bien aussi
les noms soient ces demandeurs alors les
tests rapides cela évite d'avoir leur
angoisse d'attendre le résultat le
testeur rapide ça fonctionne bien
pourquoi parce que on est dans des
opérations est nominé pour savoir alors
une minute c'est le temps du test mais
en réalité avec l'entretien et environ
30 minutes mais effectivement ça à leur
permet d'avoir des résultats
immédiatement nous on en a fait donc sur
l'année 2014 plus de 3000 et
effectivement ça un vrai engouement les
gens souhaitent connaître leur statut
sérologique mais souhaite le connaître
rapidement à l'extrême
une chose de laquelle il faut faire
attention c'est que dans le test rapide
il ya la période entre le dernier risque
pris est le test rapide qui est de trois
mois et qu'il faut bien respecter c'est
vrai qu'avec les tests sanguins on avait
fait des progrès ces dernières années
sur ce d'élèves mais les tests rapides
faut rester très stricte sur les trois
mois pour être sûr de ne pas avoir de
déconvenues donc on est négatif sur tout
ce qui s'est passé jusqu'à trois mois
avant l'arrêt d'une somme dire que
l'astreinte rod c'est le nom il faut
toujours mieux faire une vérification
c'est en tout cas le 3d positif
c'est obligatoire ziti fier un
accompagnement effectivement qui est
fait et qui est fait en tout cas chez
nous par une structure associative et
par des médecins infectieux mais quoi
qu'il en soit effectivement quand il ya
quelqu'un qui a pris des risques récents
on lui propose en général de revenir
plus tôt ali ps à l'insu promotion de la
santé soient effectivement pour faire un
dépistage ans et dg soit pour que nous
on puisse le revoir donc sur un trône
alors les autres tests ils vont être
lancées en mars prochain et non
marseillais comme on a lu partout dans
la presse - hier ils seront en place en
mars en mars avril seront vendus en
pharmacie sans ordonnance aux prix j'ai
lu une vingtaine d'euros
25 euros 25 euros ça se fera à partir
d'une goutte de sang c'est stmicro
gouvernement microgouttes de signes bros
goutte de sang et les résultats seront
disponibles en quelques minutes alors
est ce que c'est une bonne idée c'est
autotests voilà après a priori vu comme
ça on se dit on va dans une formation
prend 1 thess on se fie pour les séropos
la langue on fait quoi en fait il y aura
2 2 bonnes méthodes présentées donc par
le laboratoire soit effectivement le
pharmacien a le temps et vous souhaitez
le faire avec le pharmacien et vous
pourrez effectivement dans un camp sera
formé pour pouvoir bien entendu c'est
effectivement ce qu'on appelle un d'expo
c'est une piqûre au bout du doigt on
récupère une micro goutte de sang quinze
minutes après effectivement vous avez le
résultat positif ou négatif toujours
avec l'aspect donc trois mois puisqu'en
réalité donc ça ressemble à un troll
tout bêtement
mais si je ne vais pas le faire à 8
rentrer chez moi on peut renverser le
soir et la effective laisse tranquille
bas effectivement car nous on a fait
partie du groupe d'étude donc de
lancement des autotests on s'est
beaucoup posé la question de quel allait
être l'accompagnement effectivement ça
va se baser beaucoup sur les pharmaciens
mais aussi sida info service qui devrait
faire donc
répondent aux questions des gens en cas
de positif réorienter les gens etc mais
du coup effectivement ça pose une vraie
question
je pense qu'il faut voir ça comme une
méthode complémentaire de dépistage
clairement les gens sont pas assez des
pistes et en france on parle de 30
milles c'est peut-être plus fins de
personnes séropositifs qui s'ignorent et
qui sont à l'origine de deux tiers des
nouvelles contaminations donc une fois
qu'on a dit ça il faut absolument que
tout le monde soit dépistée donc il ya
les centres de dépistage anonyme et
gratuit il ya les associatifs qui vont
sur les lieux où on a le plus de chance
de rencontrer des gens qui sont très à
risque il ya des personnes qui vont
vouloir vendre leur médecin traitant et
faire ça en attendant qu'ils ont besoin
d'un temps de quelques jours pour
réfléchir et il ya sans doute des gens
qui veulent faire ça à eux-mêmes dans
leur coin donc effectivement la
difficulté c'est si un résultat positif
est ce que la personne est prête et a
anticipé le fait que le test pouvait
positif qu'elle se retrouverait tout
seul pour avoir ce résultat positif moi
je pense qu'il faut voir ça comme une
offre complémentaire de dépistage à 100
que le problème c'est que il faut qu'ils
aient plus de gens des pistes et
je déteste oui
il est tout seul à découvrir ça non non
pas directement la chose que c'est
important c'est bien les avancées
j'ai pas bon mais est-ce que faut se
poser la question est ce que la personne
est prêt souto tester moi je vois que tu
es trop de la femme
à conduire un questionnaire prête est lé
poste est donc on en est là avec les
gens on les accompagne que la personne
va tout seul chez lui à va rêver voici
le test que ça va faire si alain positif
est-ce qu'elle va voir la couleur la
série voilà c'est ça qui est important
de savoir comment va réagir salle
impersonnelle ce qui est important aussi
de souligner c'est que quand on est
séropositif et quand on dépiste en tout
cas des séropositifs on sait que ça les
marques avis ça que d'ailleurs que nous
on ne dépiste pas entre noël et jour de
l'an des pistes pas la saint valentin on
dépiste pas dans certaines circonstances
parce que les gens sont marqués
effectivement de qui a fait le test nous
on a des gens qui reviennent nous voir
en nous disant bas vous souvenez de moi
vous m'avez dépister il ya un an deux
ans etc et c'est vrai que pour le coup
je pense que vous aviez toi ça doit être
pareil oui c'est des lakers et on
ne brûle pas si jeune date anniversaire
donc c'est important aussi je pense
d'eux va le recul si bien ici mais en
espérant que bon les gens
enfin moi ça me fait un peu peur qu'il
s'est passé vraiment ce contrôle qu'un
petit loto test là ils seront seuls
c'est ça c'est un soudanais ça c'était
sur un ton au dessus merci en tout cas
beaucoup avouent 3 d'être venu sur le
plateau de 7,8 société nous nous parle
on aurait pu en parler encore plus
longuement mais merci beaucoup à vous
royalement nous quitte et
j'aurais rappeler quand même certaines
données qui peuvent faire tomber
certains clichés selon l'institut de
veille sanitaire 59 de veille sanitaire
par dont 56% des personnes ayant
découvert leur séropositivité 1012 ont
été contaminés lors de rapports
hétérosexuels
10 18 % des séropositifs je l'avais j'en
avais parlé tout à l'heure testé en 2012
avait plus de 50 ans 12 % avaient moins
de 25 ans voilà quelques chiffres pour
réfléchir encore merci beaucoup à vous
trois devraient participer à cette
émission c'est maintenant terminé je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée